bienvenidos a nuestro vídeo acerca de la
sustracción pero antes que nada quiero
dar un pequeño repaso acerca de la suma
de la adición así que bien si yo escribo
4 + 3 a cuánto es igual a esto qué
significa esto pues hay distintos modos
en los que lo podría pensar por ejemplo
podría pensar que tengo 4 naranjas para
el desayuno o 4 círculos o 4 cualquier
cosa tengo aquí 4 naranjas 1 2 3 4
naranjas para el desayuno y también que
tengo tres naranjas para el almuerzo así
que una dos tres naranjas entonces en
total cuántas naranjas tengo pues tengo
una dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete así
que cuatro tres nos da siete pero no es
el único modo que podría haber resuelto
esto también podría haber dibujado una
recta numérica vamos a dibujar una recta
numérica perdonen si está algo choca ok
entonces aquí empiezo aquí hasta el cero
y entonces tengo 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 déjenme les pongo nombres 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 perfecto entonces yo estoy
empezando en el 4 porque ya tengo 4
naranjas y le quiero sumar 3 naranjas
así que me muevo 3 espacios hacia la
derecha 1 2 3 recuerden partir del 4 y
me muevo 3 espacios hacia la derecha y
llegó al 7 así que 43 el 7 muy bien pero
qué pasa ahora con la sustracción bien
pues este vídeo como dije es acerca de
la sustracción o la resta así que no
quiero perder todo mi tiempo discutiendo
la adicción muy bien pensemos en un
ejemplo para la resta o la sustracción
vamos a ver qué tal qué tal 4 menos
que nos daría esto pues si la adicción o
la suma consiste en añadir cosas la
sustracción consiste en quitar las
digamos supongamos que tengo mis cuatro
naranjas del desayuno una naranja dos
naranjas tres naranjas cuatro naranjas y
digamos que hago un jugo con tres de
ellas así que ésta se va ésta se va esto
se va ya la sucede en el jugo y cuántos
naranjas me quedaron pues sólo me quedo
esta naranja de aquí que en realidad
podría haber tachado cualquiera tres y
dejar esta no no importa con qué naranja
que el jugo así que cuatro menos tres
sería uno pues sólo me queda una naranja
después de hacer el jugo otra manera de
pensar en exactamente lo mismo es de
nuevo déjenme dibujo mi recta numérica
voy a volver a poner 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 de hecho podría continuar la recta
numérica nunca termina nunca termina
porque no existe el número más grande
que todos los números si me dices
cualquier número yo te puedo en un
número más grande así que es imposible
dibujar toda la recta numérica pero
bueno con esto nos basta 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 y
5 está muy feo 5 6 7 perfecto entonces
yo empiezo en el número 4 tengo 4
naranjas al momento de iniciar mi
desayuno o al momento iniciar a preparar
mi desayuno quizás pero voy a usar 3 en
jugo entonces que imaginas qué va a
pasar si cuando sumamos nos fuimos hacia
la derecha avanzamos en la recta
numérica al restar lo que vamos a hacer
es movernos hacia la izquierda vamos a
retroceder así que voy a retroceder tres
espacios 1 2 3 y terminó aquí en el 1
así que de nuevo lo que pasó fue que
cuando empecé en el 4 y quiero restarle
3 lo que tengo que hacer es retroceder
moverme hacia la izquierda en la recta
numérica el número de espacios que
quiero restar en este
uno dos tres espacios y llegó al 1 así
que bueno a manera de un breve resumen
si lo que quiero es tomar cosas entonces
me muevo a la derecha avanzó en la recta
numérica si lo que quiero es restar
cosas entonces retrocedo o me muevo a la
izquierda pero bueno si tengo cuatro
cosas y le quito 3 es lo mismo que si
dijera que por ejemplo las perdí digamos
que perdí tres cosas entonces cuántas
cosas me quedan pues sólo me queda una
sí tengo no sé cuatro dulces y pierdo
tres me queda un solo dulce ahora quiero
enseñarles otra cosa interesante
quiero ver otro ejemplo interesante
vamos a pensar en por ejemplo 4 menos 14
menos 1 cuánto creen que sea vamos a
suponer que aquí tengo mis 4 dulces un
dulce dos dulces tres dulces cuatro
dulces y le regaló uno a mi amigo porque
no le voy a regalar este de aquí
entonces se lo regalo ya no lo tengo
cuántos dulces me quedaron pues me
quedaron uno dos tres
tres dulces o si lo quieres pensar en la
recta numérica lo que tendrías que hacer
es en pieza del 4 y retrocede un espacio
te vas un espacio a la izquierda así que
me muevo para acá
y quedó en el 34 menos 1 estrés no es
interesante
4 - 3 me daba 1 y 4 menos uno me daba 3
y vamos a ver esto con más profundidad
quizás en la materia de álgebra no me
quiero adelantar mucho pero es
interesante no y de nuevo recuerden no
importa cómo piensan en estos problemas
si los quieren pensar con bolitas o
manzanas o si los quieren pensar en la
recta numérica les va a dar siempre el
mismo resultado
ok también quiero que pienses en el
siguiente ejemplo quiero que pienses en
cuánto es 3 + 1 cuánto es tres más uno
pues veámoslo aquí en la recta numérica
en primer lugar si estoy en el 3 y
avanzó uno a la derecha avanzó 1
entonces a donde llegó pues llegó aquí
al 4 así que tres más uno es cuatro o
quizás también lo podrías hacer con las
manzanas o que eran naranjas las
naranjas del desayuno pero eso te lo
dejo de ejercicio entonces tres más uno
es cuatro porque si estoy en el 3 y me
muevo uno a la derecha llegó al 4
y de 13 de que me usó otro color vamos a
poner esto muy colorido y muy alegre
entonces qué hay de 1 + 3 cuánto me da
esto pues si estoy en el 1 y avanzó 3
entonces déjenme lo hago ahora por abajo
1 2 3
así que a donde llegue pues de nuevo
llegué al 4 las dos cosas me dan lo
mismo sumar tres más uno es lo mismo que
sumar uno más tres y ambas me dan cuatro
así que bueno esto es lo que es
interesante piénsenlo
4 - 1 era 3 y 1 3 es 4 qué quiere decir
esto por un lado quiere decir que si
estoy en el 4 y me muevo un espacio de
izquierdas y retrocede 1 llegó al 3 pero
si estoy en el 3 y me muevo un espacio a
la derecha llegó al 4 así que todas
estas cosas en realidad están conectadas
pero bueno esto es una pequeña
introducción al tema de la sustracción o
de la resta en el próximo vídeo haré la
mayor cantidad de ejemplos que pueda
para que esté
ya estén listos para hacer los
ejercicios por su propia cuenta nos
vemos pronto